so it seems pretty clear Democrats are
going to lose big on Tuesday and they
know it and they're panicking as a
result of that and they've gone
basically completely nuts here's
Congressman Jim Clyburn of South
Carolina
this is what happens in a country that
follows what happened in Germany in the
early 30s this country country is on
track to repeat what happened in Germany
when it was the greatest democracy going
elected a chancellor who then co-opted
the media
that this past president
uh Cohen depressed the enemy of the
people that is the bunch of crap and we
know it
and that's what's going on in this
country
so Weimar Germany was the greatest
government ever really Weimar Germany
was great and Republicans are Nazis
it's hard even to know where to start so
we've asked Victor Davis Hansen from the
Hoover institution to join us tonight
Professor thanks so much for coming on
what do you make of all this thank you
it's just nonsense and uh the only way
we can look at it Tucker is that we
haven't had 90 years the left sees the
control of government and they have the
Congress the executive branch it's not
that we you know it's not that we have a
border that's open they blew up the
Border it's not they're letting
criminals out they blew up the criminal
justice system it's not that they shut
down animal they blew up the whole idea
of self-sufficiency and energy and when
you ask them about it they won't defend
it they won't say well we got three
million illegal aliens isn't that great
no they don't talk about it and they
won't change they won't say well let's
build up you know 100 miles of the wall
or let's reopen Keystone so all they do
instead is they have a mantra it's a
trifecta they said if you're going not
to vote for Democrats if you don't vote
for a Democrat you destroying democracy
and every woman in the United States has
a constitutional right to have an
abortion to the last minute before birth
and Donald Trump and his supporters half
the country are fascists the only good
thing out of of this toxic two years
that we've endured we Lab Rats from one
of these mad scientists is that in a
weird way they brought people together
Tucker there have been there's a new
ecumenical movement of African-American
males Hispanics and the white working
class that detest these by Coastal
Elites and they're starting to look at
class concerns rather than these racial
differences and just the the antipathy
toward these left-wing Elites has
created a consensus that I haven't seen
in my lifetime but I think we're going
to be shocked next Tuesday when it Roars
it's going to be a mouse and it's going
to Roar and they're not ready for it and
that's why they're panicking they don't
know what to do
I I think you're I mean I've been a
coastal Elite my whole life and I could
not have more contempt for them and I
mean that from the bottom of my heart so
you think just to bottom line it for us
since you're a historian you think this
will be
a realignment next Tuesday
I I do and I think we paid a hell of a
price to put up for two years with this
insanity but there will be some good out
of it because people saw in the Raw
nihilism and socialism and what they saw
was ugly and they don't want any part of
it and it's going to bring people
together that no one ever would imagine
have common class interests and it's
going to be a revolt against these as I
said these bi-coastals snarky Elites
nobody likes them and then we're going
to find out on Tuesday just how much
they don't like them
man you're making you're making me happy
just saying that the great picture Davis
Hansen thank you so much great to see
you tonight thank you
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight